whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up the state
of California for pulling the plug on
electric bingo machines it sounds like a
small issue but charities say it's going
to cause a big cash crunch west
hollywood california for banning the
sale of most dogs and cats at pet stores
up but there can be only one nanny of
the month and this time it's kansas
state representative Robert Olson for
leading the charge to ban fake pot
that's right Kansas is expected to ban a
marijuana imitator that goes by many
names Black Mamba pep spice bliss dragon
and Bombay blue and don't forget k2
Stardust andso hi whatever you call it
some use the herbal concoction to get
high legally and that's why Kansas is
poised to be the first state to ban it
and why plenty of other states are
poised to follow so thanks
representative Olsen for launching us
into a whole new kind of reefer madness
check back next month for more examples
of busybodies minding your own business